We might know about viruses because
they can infect us and cause diseases
like the flu, herpes and smallpox. In
fact, viruses come in all shapes and
sizes and can affect all life forms on
Earth, including animals, plants, and
even bacteria.
Viruses are everywhere on the planet.
In fact, one teaspoon of seawater has
10 million viruses in it.
But what exactly is a virus? Viruses
are made of an outer shell that holds
genetic material. This genetic material
is the recipe for viruses to make more
viruses, but viruses don't have the
tools to make more of themselves.
They need to borrow tools from another
life form, or host. Viruses infect
cells, the basic unit of life, which
have all the tools the virus needs to
copy itself. To get at the cell's
tools, the virus first needs to put its
genetic material inside of the host
cell. Once the genetic material is
inside, viruses can then immediately
make more copies of themselves which
are then released into the environment,
resulting in the death of the host
cell. Other times the virus chooses to
hide and wait until the host is
stressed and weakened before making
more copies of itself. Host cells, like
bacteria, have evolved many types of
defenses against viruses.
For example, bacteria have evolved
protein scissors to tear apart the
genetic material of viruses as soon as
they enter the cell. Studying such
tools has helped many fields of
research, like genome editing. While we
tend to only think of viruses is bad,
viruses can also be helpful in the
environment.
For example, some viruses in the ocean
recycle nutrients by killing their host
cells, which provides food for other
organisms.
Viruses can kill us, but without them
we wouldn't be here.